[Music]
first of all I'll tell you more about
myself like I'm community manager for
Jensen Jensen with the topic modeling
open source project if you're here for
the previous talk you've seen topic
modeling apply to channel 4 viewer
data which is very interesting we also
have other algorithms rather than just
topic modeling itself we also have word
embeddings it's a two parts of jetsam is
public modeling and word embeddings so I
will talk about word embeddings today
and the package is used widely
throughout industry now we have you know
many industry adopters and at the same
time we have about 500 academic
citations so we are at this intersection
between academia and Industry that's
what we do we take some academic paper
maybe it comes with some cheat codes and
they have variable names like alpha and
gamma and you know no comments and we
turn into Python codes with some maybe C
extensions and make it easy to maintain
easy to use something witches can be
used in production yeah and we have a
mailing list and active community we
also have a coding sprint today at 1:30
in afternoon where we'll ask people to
come in and go through our tutorials to
find if they can improve our tutorials
Masek some small easy bug issues so you
are welcome to join if interested more
and public modeling core word embeddings
I'll talk about more later cool so the
craze for this talk go to a student they
have a student program where we mentor
students around the world
it's a remote program so the work has
mainly been done by Perl she's under
gradient student at University of Delhi
in India like I'm like we met every week
for you know half an hour and Skype for
you know several months and then she
created most of the things that I'm
going to be talking to you about and in
general have a large in creative program
you know have many students yes you in
here who's working on the master's
thesis like please come to talk to me
afterwards
very nice if you want to publish a blog
post about it or contribute to open
source as part of your education cool
okay so let's come to the main part of
the talk so which words are some
so I'll show you a pair of wards and
you'll tell me if that's similar or not
so cold I'm sure I did similar I'd like
if your finger is similar raise your
hand
okay so most people think that similar
and I agree that simple can you tell me
why that's similar what huh they like
the same let's see look coastal things
but there's a difference between them
have a different meaning yeah they used
in the same context okay any other
definitions okay you have the same
definition okay they have a same meaning
the context are the same but also the
meaning is the same
okay they're nouns okay that's something
in general between them
two Shores something or okay oh yeah and
two coasts exactly yet the coast is like
the driver like in relaxed way yeah
without any effort so that difference in
some way okay so maybe is announced they
symbolize verbs are different that's
hard okay what about close we close it
are they similar but like I put my
clothes in the clothes that they're late
it you know like have a website could
close it that comments about clothes men
are similar okay how things are similar
okay one two three four five six seven
eight okay and everybody can stand out
soon
neither chase so there's similar in a
sense that they're related down the same
topic you know and that's like clothes
versus shark that's a different words
close the closet that's similar but they
also different okay
and other way I can say that they're
different and why it's because they're
not interchangeable you can say like you
know I'm put on my clothes I can't say I
put on my closets so in that sense the
ads that are different and the context
in which I use them is also different
you know I can't say I could put on my
clothes I put in my my closet but the
topic is the same but it's but they're
different so I think means they have two
different notions of similarity here at
least one of them is about topic and
other is about how they interchangeable
are not interchangeable and this thing
they can answer different business
problems depending on what you want you
want to be answered you have to define
what similarity wants you know and
like this if you want to this is from
Pride and Prejudice you know like
there's a to business problem so you can
ask about Pride and Prejudice now what
does Elizabeth think about mr. Darcy
she's like a general broad topic
question or you can want to know what
about what a male characters in Pride
and Prejudice that's a very you know
specific interchangeable you know words
question you know what does it what are
the words I can to change for Darcy and
then you can find all the male
characters that way and you know in
serious business you would have in this
kind of business questions you know
what's that words in the topic of Darcy
or what are the named entities in text
who are male and this is you have to use
two different notions of similarity to
answer these two different business
questions and today I will talk about
different alternates and different -
parameters you can do to find this
similarity algorithms and you'll be able
to tune them to choose which similarity
you want so you know how which are going
to pick and which have a parameters to
use that'll be the purpose of today's
talk okay so this example of two models
claim Pride and Prejudice and this first
one is the blue is just a topical model
you know it shows you the attributes of
Darcy and you see that that things like
smile composure surprised this is just a
general topic of Darcy and the second
model is for interchangeable words you
know what are the other male characters
which are in the book and you see like
mr. Wickham mr. Bingley you know and
other male characters which are there in
the book and I'll show you how to train
these models later you know how to get
the high parameters to get this two
different kinds of similarity any
questions so far
cool cool so this is a example of
something just trained on a bigger
corpus when just Pride and Prejudice
right pressure is just a couple of
hundred thousand words and this has been
trying to be Kapisa expedia 70 million
words and there you get the much better
matches so there's a three different
algorithms and you get three different
kinds of similarity
so here's war drunk get attributes of a
king so and if you use words avec you
get into changeable words of the king
and if use five texts to get a mix of
- that way so she forward rank you gets
you know throne because King sits on the
throne you know get to know king was
crowned in the monarch thanks a child in
the general topic of the king you know
similar to how clothes and clothes it on
the same topic that's what you get from
Ward rank forward to back you just get
names of kings and this is the thing
that's interchangeable of king you know
just how you get Darcy you get other
male characters or coast and shore that
quite interchangeable and that's way so
you get the interchangeable similarity
Oh in five takes to get them in so mix
of both these are the two kinds of
similar to be described in literature
mainly so let me go into the theory
first and then I'll go into the code how
to run the stuff so okay okay so what is
a word embedding yeah I've been using
this word for a while and the word
abetik is the way to assign a vector to
a word in general if I have a words
there's some very easy way to assign a
vector to it I can just have a one hot
embedding a vector which is you know 1
Million numbers long and I have 1
million words in my vocabulary I take
just 1 million you know numbers long
vector and I just do one hot embedding
so I turn on the first bit if it means
the first word for Kings will be my
first word to turn the first bit Queen
will be my second word I'll turn on the
second bit for the Queen and the rest of
there will be zeros so I have this
really long vector which only has one
non-zero entry it's called one hot
embedding that's the easiest way to just
you know embed so many discrete values
into a vector and the annoying thing
here is that it's really long I just
have to store this million numbers of
memory and also I can't really see the
similarity between words you know king
and queen
I don't know how if there's anything
king and queen with very different the
same ways like king king gene book look
very different like it doesn't there's
no information about relationships
between the words in here that's a not a
very nice way there's no semantics and
it takes lots of lots of memory but yeah
you can say that so the solution to that
is to have a small representation just
you know pick you know three dimensions
or hundred dimensions but there you're
not going to have 0 one you're going to
have real numbers in there so you have
like 0 94 for gaining Egyptian sevens
you're 20
- just some numbers in there and what
about ink is this called a dense
representation of words in a low
dimensional vector space it's not going
to be as high as this it's going to be
you know usually a hundred dimensions of
300 dimensions there's a usual number of
dimensions people choose for the word
embeddings and let's say for debate ink
is the same as saying a word vector or
same as saying distributed
representation and it's to bridge a
representation you know it's not
laughing - the distributed computing
just it's only connection meaningful to
our distributed is that the meaning is
spread through this three dimensions
here it's not just concentrated in the
first one for the King I just spread
like you know across all the free so
there's no like one one access in there
which is has the if the King access
usually spread across all the three of
them that's what it's what model it
means for distributed representation
cool any questions on the definition
haven't you have seen word embeddings
before okay most of the room cool so I
can move slightly faster for the theory
then okay so this is a very nice
visualization you can do it in terms of
board gen theme has ways to convert all
the Genting models into tensor board you
can take you know any gents model and
plot it in this nice way this is you
know t-sne for from 100 dimensions to
free and you know i tweak the parameters
of TCE I get something slightly
different I do PCA I guess I'd something
a slightly different I don't really
believe in this visualization is very
much like I believe in this table much
better but you know I cannot bring it to
a client meeting you know I have to you
know bring something good fancy this
which is rotating and it's quite cool
but you can see like the king is here
and like regicide you know royalty
kingship like this words I really like
somewhere nearby
yeah the coolest ten words not always
appear on this graph right the closest
ten words to the king so it's kind of
nice to see if you model make sense but
I won't rely on it as my main tool like
I would much much more rely on tables
like this as my main tool which is just
calculate the closest words and this
that I would rely on but it's still you
know shows you the idea that I could how
about I get the directors for the words
and they all float in the space this is
a illustration of what what in boredom I
think is cool so the question is how to
come up with this vectors so how do I
find a good vector for King and a good
vector for Queen and I need to I need to
get a co-occurrence matrix credit yeah
the but the credit for the slide goes to
at a graph instead it's from a very nice
oxford Khorsandi panel key it's better
than ps2 the 4d it's a next level of
that so if you haven't looked at it
please look at the Oxford CSV Penelope
2017 course it's really nice so okay so
to collapse a vector I have to start
with some information about my text and
previously somebody said that close to
ensure the same because they appear in
the same context and context is very
important I'll show you how we work with
context here so this time I have been
over four sentences about cats and dogs
of course so in the cute kitten third
you know about something about the cats
and that sense about the kitten and then
about the dog and I extract the context
from my corpus so kitten has appears
next to cute bird cute again and then
mount so cute bird amount they add a
context words of kitten those are the
things that it intersects with in same
way for the cat and same in similar way
for the dog the interesting thing that's
a cute a kitten is cute here and keeping
this cube here again so cute appears
twice in as a friend of people like as a
neighbor of kitten that peer twice so
let's turn it this and turn this let's
turn this into a matrix
cymatics will have the context words
this way and the central words this way
so if kitten and cute so kitten cute
appear twice together in the same
sentence and I think we have meld now
didn't didn't make it and third in make
it but yeah so have cat you have cat is
very appearing together
you know the cute cat as well and it's
dog and fairy appeared together that's
already if I just take this row it's
actually a very nice representation of a
word already that's actually quite good
because I can see that if I do like say
kitten and cat they have cute in common
and you know dog and cat they have fur
in common so I can see that they're
somehow related
and probably kitten and cat are more
related than the dogs and then the dog
and cat if I just look at what's of the
common features that they have that's
already quite good the only problem of
this is that it is you know my rank of
it like this way like with my vocabulary
but that's fine and this way the length
is also all my context words so it's
going to be a million by million again
so it can be really big metrics that's
that's the problem with this matrix
already so I have to do some
dimensionality reduction store I start
from my code from my co-occurrence
matrix here which is my X it is really
big and just you know dimension is vaca
by vocab and I want to factorize it
factorizing matrices is you know what
they teach you in linear algebra course
and people have been doing it since the
70s just it's a very old technique just
a key metrics and factorize it into
something smaller usual dimensionality
reduction so I have you know dimensions
would leave a cop x small and small x
woke up and the row in this matrix will
correspond to the words so the first row
will tell me what the something about
the kitten that's that's all it's
happening in all world headings yeah
there's some interesting story that it
wasn't always of this so that's what
happening in all word embeddings but
I'll talk about it later
cool so the only question is how to come
up with estimate races what they should
be there many might exploit ization
algorithms out there
so in word track I want my code current
score to be say the dot product it's
more like PMI and you know there's some
other terms in there but just let's
assume for today that is just the dot
product of some vector for the word and
the vector for the context that's all I
want to get in inverter back so on the
dot product of this two vectors to be
somehow related to the
the co-occurrence count so kitten and
cute that appear lot together
so this would be hi and you know talking
cute never appear together that should
below that that kind of logic should
happen here
cool so that's the logical for Tyvek I
just have you know vector I have one
word and we'll have one word I have one
vector yeah and five text is another
algorithm it's another word embedding
which came out to now goes from Facebook
and it was present before and what pal
web it and you can probably do it
somehow yourself but it's really gotten
you know more pop more popular since the
August cool and there they use this
trick where they don't look at words
they look at sub words and okay it
didn't make it on the big screen so this
should be used up word dot V so it's
just a sum you sum over all vectors
vectors for all the sub words you have
in there and dot it with your context
word so you no longer look at one word
one vector you have one one word many
vectors and for example if I look at the
word going I'll have many vectors for
that I'll have go have oh you have in
and G Google in an Inc there's a my old
my two and free grants are there and
this is kind of like a poor man's
morphology like if I if I'm a human like
I look at going in school they told me
that you know go is the roots and Inga's
like the ending computer doesn't know
that theater doesn't can it do that they
didn't go to school so all I can do is
just like hockey way you just like take
all the combinations of letters in there
you know contiguous combinations and see
which one has the most meaning and
that's like maybe if I like average all
of them I'll find something meaningful
like I'll probably guess that goal is
like important roots and it lets give me
an important vector for that and I'll
probably in blue have a lot of meaning
for me but I'll just figure it out by
trying all the combinations it's a poor
man's morphology distinct engrams to the
poor madman prodigy oh yeah that should
not be there that should be going yeah
you're right Joey yeah that should be G
oh why do I thank you you know
there's a more example status there's
one the correct they don't have any
things think cool so fast text is better
than the word Tyvek because you have
morphology because you don't have a one
vector for board they have many vectors
for words for many different parts of
the word and you can you know all this
words will be related goal related to
goals and going related to go because
they'll have this sub word goal that
they all share and yeah like it shows
how they all share I mean it was you
know colors and green the program is
this is slower and instead of coming up
with one vector for going I have to come
up with you know one two three four and
many more vectors which are just for the
little sub parts of it so it means my
runtime will be much much longer and
that's annoying and my vocabulary be
much much much bigger and yeah so it
means I have to spend more time training
my model that's the knowing that is
slower cool but it is better at two
changeable words there's you know how we
discussed this two kinds of similarity
there and we have two different kinds of
tests for them we have a just a list of
words which is similar in related way a
list of words which are similar in
interchangeable way and we can test our
audience on that so for later words
their last text and you know word Tyvek
that is saying yeah mr. Jensen it means
Jensen were terrific but when the
changeable words pass text you know like
blows everything out of the water if you
use this engrams because in the
changeable words you know nice and
nights these are the kind of thing to
have in there and of course if you know
if you look at their roots of that
you'll be able to get it much better
than just thinking at night nights I'm
not related at all and then finally
sleep here in the same context I guess
they're the same it's much easier to
just look at the sub words than to think
about context yeah and that's that's why
so fast text really wins at this
interchangeable words accuracy and this
is you know like you can see this big
graph it's a train in a very small
corpus and logic report just gets more
yeah
it still it still wins even a logic
report
so this is the ipi for fostex
we have a wrapper and it's the same
things that you would use forward to
back embedding and a word to back is old
has been around for about three years
and you don't have to change a code much
if you want to switch the past text you
just use the same API in gem same as you
would there it's maybe take you longer
to train and you have to install fast
text but gentle API is the same and you
see I can check if the word Knights is
in my vocabulary have I trained with the
word Knights
no the answer is false so I have never
seen the word nice before in training
and the only the only word I seen is
night and some other you know related
words but if I look at the similarity of
19 Knights you can still answer it for
me because some of the anger and some of
the little bits upwards of Knights are
contained in my training center
specifically Knight is there it seemed
my during training so it can guess that
Knights it's related tonight and it
gives me 97 similarities begins slash is
very high for now and for today I cannot
do this
what avec is like a fixed of cobbler
technique you cannot add new verse stood
and specifically even if you add new
words to it you have to train it for a
long time to explain toward to AK what
these new words mean what pasta just
guesses it because of this share some
sub words and that's that's how it works
uh-huh if it's never seen it before
oh yeah actually because it yeah it will
show that a quite similar yeah if you
start in a small corpus it turns on a
big one then the context will take over
but if you train it like 1 million or
like yeah half a million and yeah it
will show them as a similar that's which
is unfortunate
yeah I should I should add night here as
an example ok yeah for next one cool any
more questions
the this doesn't do this the switching
around doesn't work for that like the
fact of the cake call Conan chin that
might be there but the servation and
their station they're very different I
would expect them to be quite different
yeah perform this sort of experiment
will become quickly sort of limiting
because English is sort of clean with
yes if you get I'm Italian and I cited a
little bit of French and it was two
languages for example you get a lot of
big verbs you get a mess too from
Batman's you could actually get from
small angles you could get like a what
potential it is in the past including
the future who is while actually I don't
eat Italian is stricter now is a
language from like the 60s exactly
actually language because of television
but still there are like very dialects
of Dutch dialects are mostly something
like a influence and change yeah it is
it ultimately it is it is cheating like
using this thing for English is really
cheating English has very simple
morphologic and parrot other languages
and fast text the Facebook team has
released 78 trend models from 78
languages from Wikipedia and the more
complicated morphology so that language
the more fast legs bits words back there
so it's definitely not designed for
English it's designed for language to
complicate morphology like Russian or
you know polish or Portuguese or Italian
yeah so definitely English is not the
best example that will come on to the
minute we in this room so that's example
I like to show you yeah there was a nice
talk yesterday about fast text for
French and Russian and translation by
Bob you on health cool so I already
mentioned that that is it slower
the fast text is slower than words avec
just because they have more back
that you need to come up with but the
weird thing is even if I disable this
feature of like having any vectors to
come up with it I'll just say like only
think about words and I have this two
algorithms that should be exactly the
same thing one is written in C files
text is written just pure C now this one
in Python with some a little bit of
siphoning you know bits which are
computation intensive in there and they
should do should run the same actually
see you know it's perceived as a faster
language in the Python but somehow
whiten runs faster and you know and if I
if I disable all the engrams feature if
I just say like the maximum support you
should use is zero length and just you
know the two words vectors forward here
like this for there and then you know
somehow C is still slower than Buyten
and you know it's and PI data happy to
share this view it's not not by much but
it is still slightly slower cool
so we described three ways to get the
vector forward but they're generally
have many ways to do that
so we just got talked about vort avec
fast text and now i'll talk about word
ranked third there is just much simpler
ways to just factorize the metrics i
could just you know SVD or it's just
called LSI if I apply 3d to
co-occurrence matrix and that's a nice
thing to do it's been around since the
70s there's nothing new about it and oh
yeah does anybody know when word Tyvek
paper was published 2012 yeah
and it's published by Michelob may come
up with a deep learning guide here just
a deep learning researcher he says on
paper where people were coming up of
this word vectors in a very complicated
deep learning way and he just come up
with a simpler way to do it maybe just
use the one layer network and that will
just be enough that was the purpose of
his paper didn't know anything about
natural language processing can always
call currents matter states and
distributed semantics he just had a
neural network model and if you read his
paper there's nothing really about
co-occurrences in there and then later
live in goldberg they prove that doing
this neural network thing is the same
it's factorizing cat Corcoran's metrics
in some way so they made it linked it to
all these old techniques in reality in
the seventies but for Tyvek
became popular that's because the code
was there was faster on there was a
paper around and just worked and that
became very popular great even though
these similar things have been around
for a long time before but you know if
you release your paper to give us a nice
code which is performance then you'll
become popular even though some
allegation before for 100 for a long
time yeah in front of it but like tens
of years and now we will see it all in
perspective how they all trying to do
the same thing just by factorizing this
yeah that factor I think is called
currents metrics in different ways so
there are other embeddings out there
glove swivel you know eigen boards and
VAR embed they all doing very similar
things where embed is interesting
because Varna bed actually has an honest
morphology I have to have a morphology
package which extracts roots for you and
then you can do embedding based on
morphology yeah that's quite nice but
takes very long time to run that's the
only problem with that thank you
you don't know just doing more apology
honestly it's harder than just doing
something Heike by taking you know every
two or three letter combinations from
inside of your word cool so let's move
to war drank so war drank is the ranking
algorithm words avec is a classification
problem and word rank is a ranking
algorithm so in words avec I have my
context you know cute and I'm going to
predict what's the most likely word in a
context and they've word which is most
likely it's kitten because kitten
appears of cute twice in my corpus so
okay cute is the best friend you know
it's kitten so just I just want to find
out how one word as an input one word as
an output that's what word to back that
swimming war drunk thinks about it
differently and when it gets a word cute
what wants to produce out is a ranking
so I want to produce a list of words
where you know the first one is going to
be kitten because cute some kid
materialized second is going to be cat
cats and cats was cute ones
and third one's gonna be dog dog was
never cute so it'll be just the third
one and they're lost function here is
quite robust it's the mr. if I make
mistake at the top that costs me a lot I
make mistake at the bottom you know
number 10 20 I don't care about it that
much
and that
it makes it much more robust to noise if
something's randomly appear together and
that's you know mistake happens at the
bottom I don't really care about that
but if things appear to get very often
that's very important to me that's
probably the main meaning of the word is
there at the top it's a different
formulation of the problem and you can
use the whole of learning to rank
methodology there like I didn't know
about learning to rank until I
discovered word rank it's a very nice
area and you can apply it to many
different problems actually in the
designs anyone heard about learning to
rank before okay one to two people free
okay four okay so maybe this was special
to me but yeah you should check it out
some tutorial ISM ltr' and that's very
good results for the world of innings
they have a word rank pepper the IPI is
the same as forward to back you know
just train it at the same way to which
one train board to back and it gives you
the most similar words and you can see
like when I use any model in women I
want to use word to back I still look at
the ranks so the way it actually we're
debating is I use it slowly ranking
problem and it's a very natural
implement definition of the problem is
to think about its ranking because
usually I just do get more similar and
what's the most similar you know three
five ten most singular words that's how
I validate them there's been trained on
a small corpus like lead corpus yeah and
this is the result you get for that but
do you that di is the same so it's very
easy you want to switch to were drunk
from word to back you don't need to
change your code much just how you train
it but their query code will be the same
injunction cool yeah okay there's more
freedom is intense aboard so but now
it's a board rank embedding which is
liked it different cool so let's do some
evaluations so this is when it was
trained on 1 million corpus okay I have
five minutes to go
when 1 million corpus you can see this
word rank takes four hours to run you
know it's a much harder problem when you
want to predict the whole rank round
just one word and other things are just
seconds you know less than the minutes
and there's you know many passes but if
we run a small corpus 1 million is a
small corpus I get really high accuracy
for related once the directive things
are cloves and closes this kind of
similar
it come up really well here and because
it of the thing their nature of rank
includes it's quite robe yet looks at
quite a large context around it yeah
the interchange of accuracy is not so
good for ordering but the related ones
yes that's where it beats the other
things out of the water sample to get
something like the initial paper claims
that if you have 17 million words you
get the same light accuracy as if you
train board to back on 17 billion but so
you know you can get the same result but
on a smaller corpus with were drunk if
you correlated similarity if you care
about just general topics you should use
the word rank and I'll have a decision
tree in the end it shows you what to use
mine this is 17 million this is
Wikipedia and it takes 40 hours to run
word rank on Wikipedia while the other
things are just you know half an hour
you know under yeah definitely an hour
this is seconds and this was hours okay
yeah and here related accuracy forward
rank is still the best still very good
at related one so your fast text is
coming up close and you know
interchangeable fast X is coming up
close its close as well cool okay let's
talk more about have a parameter tuning
so the window is how far left and right
I go so when I have the kitchen in the
middle and setting your cute kitten
jumped over the fence sometimes you know
I have cute and jumped as my neighbors
of kitten or if I want to have a window
one for example I don't have my window
free I have you know cute kitten jumped
over the fence they're all going to be
neighbors of kitten so depends how far
less and how far right I go in my
documents to see what are the neighbors
of that word and you can see how things
change as I increase the window Oh for
example when I trained this model to
four interchangeable words I use the
very small window because I use it like
Darcy you know Road it's the same like
parts eroded our society Darcy moved but
the same way is like Bingley moved on
Bing Bing Lee Road I had this you know
male adjectives next to the male name so
I only looked like putting towards
laughing towards right and that's how I
got two interchangeable model for yeah
for the for Pride and Prejudice and if I
look at the bigger window
I get less interchangeable stuff but I
get more related stuff so you can see
that as the windows growing so I like to
1550 as the windows growing my related
accuracy is growing so it becomes more
topical you know if a doctor and a
profession of somebody appears you know
usually like ten words away from the
actual name but disappear together a lot
and they will become closer together and
the changeable accuracy goes down as I
increase my window depending on what
accuracy you want what's the molarity
you want you have to choose the window
appropriately and that's yes that's true
for words back is true for partek so for
drunk it's not not so sensitive to this
parameter what drunk is just focuses on
related mainly that way so this is quite
a nice thing to play with a changeable
small window related big window cool so
this is a table how to catch the virus
you need so if you want to find
something related and then want to
describe the words topic and I want to
know what the document is vaguely about
like I want to know which department
should I send the support email to then
I should use in a war drunk
even on a small corpus it would work
quite well over to back if I have a big
corpus with a big window or if I you
know fine named entities in the text I
want to find you know what is similar to
Java senior developer specifically
that's the same as you know lead Java
developer then I would use
interchangeable stuff and I'll use a
voice of X key brand small window fast
texture environment okay and this is a
decision tree for the same table so my
similar words are related and I got a
million words yes use word to beg for
large context no I have something small
were drunk is your best shot that way if
you want something related the
changeable words yeah you use any one of
this free and flat text should be your
first choice
nowadays like in a year from now I think
nobody will be using words back
everybody using fast text and the other
one I think so let's think cool yeah so
thanks for listening we'll have a coding
spring today if you want to contribute
to open source or just learn someone LP
yourself it's been very nice if you come
in try to run out tutorials the turtles
were designed for like you know version
which was six months ago it might learn
and Jensen my son
mas with voltages in 2.0 some of it
might not but just like it's very
helpful as if you run for them and maybe
some things they don't understand and we
explain it to you in the change the
toriel better like link it to Wikipedia
or something so if you want to learn
more about Mt please come to the sprint
well if you want to you know do one one
stuff you're welcome to take some easy
bug and github well if you want to do
your wonderful work for full facts
yesterday what you did you know Dave
here yeah you can do that you can turn
that into a dancing tutorial it'll be
quite nice little cool now we have time
for questions you still do cosine
similarity yeah the the when you dissin
large is still cosine this is the same
method as before it just your objective
function is as designed it's like it
sums over all the words and when the end
over rank and besides the highest
ranking words that way but it still
cosine any more questions uh-huh uh-huh
yeah you can still do average average
words for anything you can do average
with five sites you can average with
word rank there's no specific tricks out
there yeah I haven't heard of doctor
Beckwith engrams but it can probably do
them today event grams as well you just
you know split your corpus into engrams
before and if you did to dr. back you
can you can have you know fast dr. Beck
even though it's slower but you can call
it that way yeah any more questions yeah
words are you sort of do do it on full
scale at work to back and then once
you've started what you want then switch
over to word practically like a bit the
air training later use one of these
Google be better yeah like if you train
it on words avec and you get this like
you know your accuracy that you get and
you usually you have a this is an
civilized training so you very hard to
evaluate it intrinsically you only know
how useful it is somewhere downstream so
you have some supervised problem down
there and you train your word civic
model and 1 million words it's really
fast and you see like micro she did not
increase at all then I would give up and
not do anything but if I see it increase
into this cleaner by like you know half
percent or two percent then okay maybe
where the beddings are useful here so I
would go more into the chute and train
word rank for a long time and see what's
happening there yeah so there's
definitely right path to just try board
the bedding if it's useful for you
because sometimes the you know if my
corpus is quite small tf-idf works
really well and I don't need to go to
anything advanced to this so I have
tf-idf which is fast and then I add you
know words avec and I see nothing it
changed okay so I probably don't need
word the banks here yeah so there's a
good a good exploration pop agree yeah
like that's because of habit like fostex
have been around for like a year and
both legs been around for three or four
years that's because of habit I go to
our track first but you can easily go
too fast text first it's not that much
slower yeah in general but yeah just use
more fat sex cool any more questions
yeah so yeah hero later the prince
you
[Music]